defender la libertad tiene un precio
dijo el presidente yo bailé en
referencia al incremento de los costos
de combustible para los estadounidenses
de derivados de las sanciones impuestas
contra rusia agregó que usará sin
embargo todas las herramientas a su
disposición para que los estadounidenses
no sientan el dolor de estas sanciones
en ese sentido el asesor adjunto de
seguridad nacional de alep saint de
mencionó cuatro estrategias que se están
contemplando primero coordinar las
acciones del gobierno con grandes
productores de energía que tienen
reservas y que podrían usar estas
reservas para ofrecer recursos
energéticos necesarios no solamente eeuu
sino también al mundo segundo trabajar
de cerca con estos productores para
asegurar una oferta que ayude a
balancear los mercados en caso de alguna
disrupción tercero trabajar con las
empresas energéticas para incrementar su
producción de cara al alza de precios
energéticos y cuarto dejar claro que si
putin vuelve un arma su oferta
energética esto solo aceleraría la
diversificación de los mercados
energéticos en europa y en el mundo
alejándose así de la energía rusa